in recent times there have been massive
investments by companies and firms in
internal databases and this has provided
us the means to provide an unprecedented
look at the behavior of employees the
interaction of those employees with the
firm's customers and a new way to think
about and quantify employee productivity
so my research is about taking these
very large big data sets on the internal
organization of firms to better
understand employee productivity to
better understand the design of
incentive systems and to better
understand how these two aspects and we
brought together to improve the
interaction of a company with its
customers there are two kinds of data
that we are talking about here one is on
the internal behavior of firms of the
type routinely collected by human
resources management systems or of the
type collected routinely by ERP systems
or enterprise resource planning software
which collects data on what your
employees are doing how they're spending
time on the activities and combining
this with compensation data for example
the salaries quotas commissions putting
these two aspects together we can ask
which salaries work which quotas work
which bonuses work for which sales agent
and ask the more broader question should
we have bonuses at all do quotas work
well
kotas and bonuses and commissions have
very good incentive properties because
they give you a lot of incentives to put
in a lot of effort because they form a
goal that you have to work towards in
order to earn commissions while that is
true the flipside is many people
understand that quotas and things like
these also have some bad properties
related to gaming or timing issues if
salespeople are gaming the quota in this
manner it can actually create some
really bad behavior and distortions in
the past in theory it was thought that
these distortions are interesting but
intellectually a curious may be not that
important in the real world some of the
insights that we have been able to
generate using real data from real
companies is that the magnitudes of
these distortions can be so huge that
the positive effects of quotas and
bonuses may well be overwhelmed if they
are not designed correctly because these
distortions just have a huge magnitude
different people are different there is
a lot of heterogeneity among salespeople
amongst your employees and it's not
likely to be the case that there is a
one-size-fits-all approach the value of
the data is that we can actually measure
heterogeneity in employees employee
skill and we can look at the data and
say that this employee in this
particular territory for every time we
called on a particular doctor his
conversion of a call into sales volume
is very high while some other employee
when he called on the doctor for a same
number of calls his conversion or
production of sales is very low so we
have the ability to use the data to
fine-tune contracts to the individual
employee level for example certain kinds
of employees who are quote unquote
high-powered might prefer that most of
their compensation is coming from
Commission's as opposed to straight
salary so if you hire the right kind of
employees you could make a commission
basis
work much better than if you have
employees who prefer straight salary on
the other hand if you are forced because
of institutional or within company
considerations that you can have only a
particular kind of incentive scheme you
might think well I need to hire the
right kind of employees in order to make
this incentive scheme work what I'm
trying to say here is that the hiring
and firing of employees as well as the
design of incentives to incent them have
to go hand in hand